that issue of probable cause was
something i was thinking about earlier
dan because
we've talked about search warrants
affidavits but part of all of this is
you have to have probable cause and
if it is about classified documents then
maybe we'll never know because
even though the president declassified
them are they available to look at i
don't know right i mean there's a number
of issues and you just brought up one of
them which is the president is the
ultimate authority when he was the
president on what's classified and
what's not yes there is a procedure but
let's just be clear this is
unprecedented we've never seen anything
like this in american history so if
you're gonna have a reason to break
precedent and go after your political
opponent in the past and potentially in
the future you better damn well produce
some cookies you better not produce i've
done these by the way many of these i
don't i've been was a federal agent for
over 12 years i've done warrant returns
we weren't so fancy as the fbi we wrote
it out in hand but i'm looking at this
year and i'm wondering okay so you're
about to burn down the constitutional
republic like this loser in the attorney
general office is so what's he producing
here the russian nuclear codes don't see
that uh the united states nuclear don't
see that either what is he producing is
it the file on where amelia earhart i
don't see any of that matter of fact all
i see is yes there may be maybe some
classified documents i say maybe because
we don't know if they were declassified
or not and i say okay if that's the case
he had something he shouldn't have had
there's a process for that the same
process we've done with every other
president so merrick garland wants to
burn the republic down infuriate
probably 100 million plus americans over
leather-bound boxes of documents what is
this anchorman he has a collection of
leather-bound books and what fine
colognes this is what we're burning the
country down oh are you laughing that's
funny i'm not a comedian i should have
done your show
this is it you're going to burn the
country down over what over this you
better produce something and they
haven't produced anything on the list
greg is like a box a box of documents
yeah boxes that's why i think i don't
know who will ever if we'll ever
actually see these documents until they
decide to leak it
i have to disagree with dan this is
bigger than watergate
it's bigger than 911. it's bigger than
vietnam iran all combined it's bigger
than the cancellation of base facts of
life if he actually went home with
extremely sensitive material and now he
won't give them back
what do you so what do you think why do
you think he would do that do you think
he's planning on selling these secrets
to russia or is he going to build his
own missile in bedminster he already has
the bunkers
it's a golf course joke
but um but um
it this this doesn't sound at all
hysterical does it this is not an
affidavit it's a gaffer david i just
coined that phrase um you can't take
anything seriously when it sounds like
every hoax that has come before it the
hoax thing is always it's like it starts
off with this big fireball and then it
just starts to and then everybody is
going tick tick tick tick on twitter and
they're going
the walls are closing in the walls are
closing in and then as it goes away
suddenly the media has to turn on the
supporters and say oh they're dangerous
what you're going to hear a lot of is if
it's true if it's true i heard that on
our network if it's true these three
words prefaced every single story that
turned out not true this could be if
it's true this could bring him down so
to your point dan this is going to be
about process it's going to be the most
boring thing ever he said she said about
paperwork the dullest violation you will
ever it's another process crime
wonderful an administrative goof he
didn't follow the process because he
thought he was the process and off it
goes to court meanwhile all you're left
with is merrick garland looking like a
depressed owl cartoon and donald trump
absorbs all that energy
and he decides i'm going to run again
and he's going to use all that energy to
win or maybe he won't all i know is the
guy that's coming out on top right now
is him because this just looks hilarious
there was some some discussion today
also about uh how do you prove intent
right because um again we don't know
hardly anything but this is brett tolman
he used to work at doj he was talking
about how to prove intent
you do not have the mental state
evidence to prove that there was intent
you have to be able to show that the
president himself had the intent to take
and keep and refuse to give back
classified materials and that doesn't
even include whether or not he
designated it or declassified it it's
whether or not he had the intention and
that there are overt acts by the
president that back up the theory that
he had the intention to commit a crime
we don't have any of that
it's like this first since monday night
we we don't have any of that we now have
the search warrant but as dan was
pointed out it's pretty vague as to what
they took
i will uh point you to attachment b
paragraph c
any government and or presidential
records created between january 20th
2017
and january 20th 2021. that's every
record created during the entire trump
presidency that's what they could take
andy mccarthy texted me about this and
he said that's not evidence of a crime
at all it's not much less a crime of
mishandling classified information it's
evidence of a presidential records act
violation and that's not a criminal
statute these search warrants are
supposed to be about evidence of crimes
but this warrant allows them to take
every shred of paper related to trump's
presidency regardless of whether it's
connected to classified information
again these roughly 30 fbi agents should
have been carrying
rods and reels and buckets of bait given
what they're going in going into
mar-a-lago looking for as andy has said
over and over again
ultimate the why now is the january 6
investigation within the justice
department period end of statement full
stop that the why now is that you've had
recently the day after the mar-a-lago
search the fbi executed the warrant on
congressman scott perry for his phone
and congressman perry was the one who
introduced the environmental lawyer at
the justice department to president
trump uh john eastman um uh that not
john eastman jeffrey clark jeffrey clark
and john eastman both had search
warrants
executed on them in june
uh jeffrey clark i believe was pulled
out of his house
um
you know in pajamas when they were
searching him then you had grand jury
subpoenas recently to pat cipolloni and
patrick philbin so search warrant search
warrant subpoena subpoena
scott perry the phone and now this this
is
collect this is they are the garbage men
they're collecting evidence to
funnel to the department of justice to
support the
january 6 investigation
andy said that all along and this that
one little paragraph seems to indicate
that they take anything
anything they want uh jessica
all of trump's talking points have
exploded in his face whether it's on
stuff that he has released on his true
social account himself or the people
that he has dispersed all over
television to proliferate his lies
including his own children saying that
he didn't get a copy of the warrant
christina bob his attorney confirmed
that on our network and other networks
they did have the warrant there he said
president obama when he loves running
tattletails on himself president obama
did this too he took the nuke materials
out you know in his back pocket not true
the national records office released a
statement the president obama fulfilled
protocols 30 million documents went
through them to chicago falling protocol
respect for the law and the way that
things are done
it is too
mind-blowingly arrogant i think to sit
here and say i know exactly what's going
on and to call the attorney general the
united states of america a loser i think
that's the word that you use oh he's a
loser oh he's a real loser
i just actually
and i i have no losers
he is a total loser okay he is burning
down the constitutional republic
targeting this guy and you don't know
what's in there either yeah and i can
tell you what that's not the opinion
i can tell you what wasn't on the
hundred laptop actual pictures of him
with hookers smoking cracks guess what
ryden was not practicing
about
barack obama was a standard and paragon
of justice on the democrat side hillary
clinton literally paid a foreign spy
paid a foreign minister to produce
about this and you're citing the
democrat party as a paragraph don't make
me laugh
there and listen to you
let me finish you brought up i just
wanted a loser which he is
so if you stop being a loser i wouldn't
need to respond okay the point here is
that the former president has no respect
for the rule of law and he's shown this
over and over again he called brad
raffensberger up and he said find me 11
853 votes when he didn't like what was
happening in georgia he wanted to stop
the count in arizona and continue it in
pennsylvania we saw what happened on
january 6 where he wanted mike pence to
decertify an american election make all
of all of you at home he wanted your
votes not to count that's how little
respect he asked for and now he's
refusing to comply with rules that every
president has had to comply with and why
now because they subpoenaed him in june
and he did not comply
no i'm not making that i don't know no
i'm not yeah you are he actually met
with him on june 3rd according to
multiple yes and then after that jay
bratt who was the agent involved in this
who does overseas it was six weeks it
was six weeks since the end of june and
that was the last communication
if it was so urgent that it was so
urgent
was there a subpoena ignored by the
trump they had conversations after the
subpoena multiple conversations
this week has been so much fun with this
story because no one's getting hurt and
it's about paperwork actually the fbi
agents in cincinnati they weren't hurt
the guy was shot dead
okay so
you guys we have two more blocks you
know what i meant jessica don't throw
that everybody's condemned that let's
not bring that up that's yes
but everything i don't like donald trump
i mean i i have a tan a little bit
smaller
all right don't ever do that your hair
is really really amazing much more to
come hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else